here we are
all right
happy monday everyone i hope you had a
lovely birthing person's day
i dressed in drag to get half-priced
mimosas at brunch
it was worth it
but other people who i call jerks went
to a judge's house to protest on behalf
of abortion it seems like an ironic
thing to do on a mother's day weekend
cheer for abortions which is what
happened a motherload of manic hysterics
showed up outside the homes of u.s
supreme court justices on saturday to
protest the court's expected repeal of
roe v wade via short for versus
reminds me of an old joke
how do you get a bitter left winger off
your porch
you pay for the pizza
so here's msnbc's next democrat
cleaner-upper who moonlights as press
secretary rattling off some answer as
she pretends to still give a crap about
her current job
trigger warning you'll be seeing red
after her answer and it won't be just
her hair do you think
the progressive activists that are now
planning protests outside some of the
justices houses are extreme
peaceful protest
no peaceful protest is not extreme
activists posted a map with the home
addresses of the supreme court justices
is that the kind of thing this president
wants to help your side make their point
look i think the president's view is
that there's a lot of passion a lot of
fear
a lot of
sadness from many many people across
this country about what they saw in that
leaked document we obviously want
people's privacy to be respected
of course long history of this sort of
thing
like how far how long really i mean to
this if you see anybody from that
cabinet in a restaurant
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh i think i just aborted my eardrums
and who can forget this jackass they're
taking away fundamental rights i want to
tell you gorsuch i want to tell you
kavanaugh you have released the
whirlwind and you will pay the price you
won't know what hit you if you go
forward with these awful decisions oh he
is stupid
if i didn't know any better he sounds
like he's fomenting an insurrection
saki has since tried to clean up her
mess tweeting that she disapproves of
violence but she didn't disavow home
visits i guess she hopes not to offend
her party extremists like this one at a
church entrance on sunday
[Music]
i'm killing the
thank baby for abortion
it's got a nice ring to it america
indeed has talent
i don't know it looks like an audition
for the open chair on the view
it'll need a straight jacket
they can borrow one from sunny
meanwhile others showed up at john
roberts home drawing images of coat
hangers in chalk
which reminds me i have shirts to pick
up at the dry cleaners
there's a problem with working late at
night they're closed
they also stopped by brett kavanaugh's
home i guess this is their way of
apologizing for calling him a gang
rapist
sadly they didn't even bring a beer
there was also more chanting because as
you know that really works
ask liz warren the next time it rains
imagine but i mean seriously imagine if
your co-workers acted this way
[Music]
who is that at this hour
[Music]
you gotta stop eating apples at the
office kyle your privileged palette is
an attack on people with misophonia miso
what uh it's a medical condition where
people get triggered by uh chewing
noises okay deb it's a quarter to
midnight on mother's day can we do this
tomorrow you gotta hear about it now
johnny applegreed all of us in the 99
aren't gonna stand for your bigoted
breakfast anymore all right
stop gaslighting me i see all the euro
christian symbolism in your precious red
delicious you might as well be eating a
swastika thank you so much i'm going to
bed now oh wait wait can i have a money
for a cab
dirt bag debbie
truly
a dirt bag
so there's more protests to come they're
going to hit the homes of gorsuch amy
conan barrett and of course evil
clarence thomas speaking of thomas let's
credit the new york times for claiming
that appealing roe v wade would
ultimately end interracial marriage
which would be news to clarence
and his wife
of course it's a lie that the medias
have been pushing for days in fact alito
specifically debunked that saying
nothing in this opinion should be
understood to cast doubt on precedents
that do not concern abortion but i guess
the editors at the times didn't
comprehend his statement which is
understandable since they read at a
fourth grade level but any facts about
the supreme court opinion don't matter
because they're kind of unexciting which
is why the media has to lie and say the
appeal will end interracial marriage ban
contraception or outlaw taco tuesday
it's the gin up rage but also argue for
adding more justices to the court if the
dems had their way the supreme court
would have more people packed into it
than hunter's biden's hotel room
so never let a crisis go to waste
a phrase coined by kilmeade's barber
will it work
well as days go on our daily pressing
problems will return you know inflation
through the roof being stabbed in the
ass waiting for the bus
fact is it's gonna be hard to go protest
roe v wade when you can barely afford
the gas to get there
now i think protesting at judges homes
is illegal in all states and for good
reason the idea that you can use fear in
order to influence any decision is
obviously wrong i learned that the hard
way when i was on dancing with the stars
but oddly the media does that every day
trying to scare you which is why today
their side always gets a pass because
once they deem you evil then all laws
are meaningless it's war i mean if
you're fighting hitler then everything's
up for grabs and make no mistake if it's
monday someone on the left is calling
you hitler
because if they didn't shout and scream
at you then you might actually hear the
truth which oddly for some reason now
sounds like bill maher
i learned things this week because this
put it on the front page
that are pretty basic things that i did
not know
about abortion
like in europe
the modern countries of europe
way more restrictive than we are or what
they're even proposing if you are
pro-choice
you would like it a lot less in germany
and italy and france and spain and
switzerland did you know that i didn't
know that i learned most people who are
pro-life are women
did not know that
and obviously he's no pro-lifer he's
just older and seemingly wiser we need
more of that and less rage
but the left has literally flipped and
the whole point of the leak
was to scare the crap out of the
justices did it work it's hard to tell
they're wearing robes
let's welcome tonight's guest
yes
his pronouns are he him and sometimes
why
post-it special report bread bear
he's written more scripts than my pain
doctor tv writer and producer rob law
the only thing that stinks about him is
his name member of the rock and roll
hall of fame and nasa's advisory
committee skunk baxter
and she's like a paper towel thin white
and can absorb any liquid
boxes contributor cat tip
[Applause]
brett brett brett brett brett brett
brett greg greg by the way congrats on
the new studio isn't it nice tremendous
with a fired up audience
way to play to the crowd brett you're an
old old pro
pro yeah we drug them
also if they don't we just throw them
out if they don't make any noise do you
think these protests will sway the vote
i mean these justices they're they know
they're not going to change their minds
i mean i don't think so i don't think
that this was fully baked and there may
have been more to it but i don't think
that anything happening outside their
house is going to change how they were
going to vote i would like to say that
it's really an honor to be a part of
four guys and a lovely woman talking
about abortion
poor guys it's a good balance right she
doesn't identify as a woman
believe it believe it or not i actually
do
wow yeah could you um what the boys are
trying to talk here
they like that huh
all the time
she does that all the time brad it's
driving me crazy
anyway is this where i leave yes this is
when you go quickly you run away okay um
so you're saying has anybody ever showed
up at your house
that
yes
yeah yeah it was kind of unsettling
isn't it yeah it does and you do right
yeah yeah well it was me he showed up
was it greg who showed up
that's what i wanted to do go back to
the game i did bring some homemade
brownies or at least that's what i said
they were
skunk has a new album speed of heat that
comes out june 17th the album comes out
yes sir uh hall of fame from duby
brothers also people don't remember
so
people don't understand also steely dan
among other things but now a complete
expert in missile defense systems and
basically space weaponry correct am i
right uh more or less yes sir so i'm
getting to the point of saying that
whatever you say here has nothing to do
with the government that's correct it's
all it's all personal opinion yes i
didn't want you to get in trouble how do
you feel do you think it's part of the
speech your right to show up in people's
houses
no i just think that's wrong because
i just think it's wrong i mean there's
no
the thing i'm having a little bit of a
problem with is i'm trying to understand
the definition of all this
now if if somebody decides to terminate
a pregnancy that means one thing but in
30 states if you someone shoots a
pregnant woman
it's a dual homicide right so
first of all maybe define the terms
first before you even move to the next
section i understand it's a sensitive as
it's a sensitive situation people are
very passionate about it but there seems
to be no definition yeah there's no
basis for reason on on either side yeah
and also i think that this is a a lot of
uh
kind of a thing being kicked up because
that people don't want to talk about the
the definition so they have these
ancillary reasons i'll get to you in a
second young lady rob the other the
other thing that bill maher said which
is interesting is that the majority of
terminated pregnancies are done with
pills i mean it's not even abortion is
almost not a question anymore well
abortions are abortion rates have been
going down over the years um since roe v
wade yeah uh
but technology has made some of the
easier but it's also made one of the
reasons why i think women
um are more pro-life is because since
roe v wade for 50 years there have been
ultrasounds ultrasound technology is
much much better yeah our idea of like
what that is inside the woman's body is
a much more complicated feeling than it
was in 1972. but look find it a little
bit yeah it helps and complicate it
right but look it's like we know what
they think about the idea of going to
someone's house
to scream at them to get them to change
their mind they're against it but
they're not against it when it's for
something that they like so
this is just pure hypocrisy but the
irony about this all is that if you read
the the the elite opinion he also agrees
he shouldn't be the guy to decide that's
the whole basis of their opinion is like
it shouldn't be us who decides it should
be the elected representatives because
we live in a representative democracy
and that's how these things are decided
and so you have a bunch of people
screaming on this on the sidewalk saying
no how dare you
not
uh enact by fiat your unelected powers
that you don't think you have yeah it's
such a strange it's such a bizarre it's
like everybody needs to instead of like
arguing and screaming the law they
should just go home and read the
constitution or take an online physic uh
civics class and i think everybody will
be much happier you know this is gonna
be the best thing that could happen to
the president's laws that actually
define you can't do that yeah so how do
again this this definition thing is
driving me nuts it's uh you know it's
just one of the i just think it should i
everything should be uh decided by me
cat we were talking about this in the
group yeah right if it's gonna be a
white male why not it'd be me i mean we
had where was it who decided it was five
five white guys two oh here's the thing
there's there's a height requirement
sorry i don't make the
rules all right cat
clean it up for us take it home
[Laughter]
you know
in what respect i was like that was a i
don't mean like in the kitchen clean it
up or take it home i mean like the topic
a sexist would say
[Laughter]
yeah i think it's it's like it's the
separate issue right i mean personally i
am pro-choice in the sense that i'm not
gonna i don't think anyone else's
decision to have abortion has anything
to do with me or is my business at all i
think when you talk about the court
they're not supposed to leak these
decisions because they're not supposed
to have public input at all
um and i think it's a bad look to be
outside of anyone's house in any
circumstance because it looks like
you're trying to intimidate that person
whether that is truly what you're trying
to do or not it
certainly looks that way but if you're
standing at somebody's house and holding
a boom box
oh
that's actually the worst kind that is
good yeah
right but can i say one the only reason
someone does that is because you already
haven't like answered their calls so one
thing about these european countries
that have more restrictive laws it's
because they voted on them right the
lawmakers made the laws and the people
elected the lawmakers and
you know it's interesting when you go
through the justice system it's one
thing when you put it to the people it's
another thing that's and we'll have to
stop there very very smart very
surprising for brett
today he insulted me i insult him that's
why we love each other
that's how you keep our marriage strong
up next elon tweets about a beverage in
twitter's workforce plans to hemorrhage
what a ride hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else